now my personal encounter was with the
railroad station they build a tall
wooden fence there and the nobody was
permitted to approach the fence the word
was out that they had machine guns lined
up alongside the fence and the street
which paralleled the railroad tracks but
even then you see I was not so much
afraid of the machine guns as you know
my discipline you know I did not have
permission to sneak up on the railroad
station I had permission to go and get
something from the city by something but
I sneaked up to the fence and I was in
my care sock so I really stood out there
because I looked left and right but I
didn't say anything anybody even
soldiers so and I found a hole there it
was a raw wood fence and that was the
day when I saw my training my adipati
train and it just must have pulled into
the station that I see very with great
clarity no difficulty to recall at all
colors everything it was a cattle train
and right in front of me just about two
tracks from the
fence stood one of the wagons and I
could see some more because the hole was
large and it was just opened it was
opened by an SS soldier that I noticed
about all of the German soldiers I
didn't see Hungarians there and it was
the impression was terrible because it
was terribly packed I literally saw what
you see in pictures mothers with
children and people and old people and
little children and all the impression
was terrifying it was really packed I
mean
compressed and one man immediately
jumped off and I always remembered his
face because he looked a little bit like
my father and he must have been
something like mid-40s closing on 50 I
did not hear what he said to the German
soldier to that SS soldier but his
behavior was polite he jumped off and my
feeling was my instinct or what I'm a
dad that he was asking for water and
immediately that as a soldier with the
club of his rifle clubbed him down and
several times I - in sensivity brother
he died or whether he was later put on
the track and then I heard anyway I was
so scared and I was so upset I never saw
anything like this in my life I simply
ran away and you know this I see it
personally is the greatest energy of my
life that you know there Jewish people
were deported or on me I didn't do
anything
I panicked right not even panic not even
fear I just didn't know what to do
now my second direct experience was the
crying in the night it was summertime
and it was one of those very very quiet
nights and I could not sleep for some
reason and there was enough moisture in
the air we were quite far from the radio
station but somehow there must have been
enough moisture to carry sand and I woke
up to the sound of many people my
impression was literally thousands of
people crying I didn't know what it was
first it was it was a terrifying
impression and then I realized this is
the sound of people crying I remember
even reflecting you know that must be
children women men everybody because it
was that kind of a chorus wailing and
crying and next morning I talked to the
several other people were still left in
there in the Jesuit house and as Dan if
they heard something
our housekeeper custodian and they all
said that they heard it and I think it
was the custodian a gardener
janitor who told me that those were the
Jewish people crying because at our
station the Hungarians and armory handed
them over to the SS troops to be
deported to Germany and sometimes when
this happened the people would start to
cry and that would spread through train
and this is what we heard that night I
didn't know about the death camps as
such at that time and I didn't know
about the ovens the burning
but I personally at that moment I felt
persuasion coming up on me that these
people will be all killed and again you
see this is where I stress what I am
trying to say I wish I could live my
life today maybe I would be ready to
then learn in front of the train and
later and I don't want to sound dramatic
maybe I would have today I would call
out or protest or risk being sedan or
club down and at that time I was
immobilized it was just a feeling not or
even a feeling of what can I do there is
nothing to do just running away simply
nothing away it was it was beyond my
experience I was utterly badly bad
decree was
pass to one have all the Jews come to
area
the marketplace was 25 pounds of
personal belongings and at that time
we had our my grandmother living with us
she was in her early 60s but she broke
her leg several years before which never
completely healed and therefore she was
limping and when we had to enter the
wagons or the transportation
- a collection place she asked my cousin
in Polish to help her get on that wagon
and one of the German soldiers who
apparently understood polish said yes
I'll help you when he took out a gun
from his holster and his children
I've seen it
well we went then I understand motion
upheaval remembering but what especially
you are moved now by sin memorial sir
could you tell us
Zen reaction
and while the inhumanity somebody asking
for help
and they help us express a killing
action
did you say my
did I cry then I don't think so I don't
remember but I don't believe I cried
then I was too petrified and this is
something really nightmarish when we
came to that camp I can probably
describe something for somebody who
hasn't seen it but has seen the film the
apocalypse now we came at night
and were surrounded by a group of people
was yellow faces
begging for scraps of bread covered with
blankets
and typical muscle minds
as it we found out the following day
work see
was fabricating the chemicals name EP
Queen to fill the shells
this is the explosive thing that
explodes in their artillery shells and
working with that chemical your lifespan
is only three four months your skin
turns yellow you shrivel and this will
be the Crenn airs surrounding us I can
say that the Kemp's taught me a lot
I'm matured quite a bit
and I'm glad I didn't lose humanity in
in the camps I felt that
there is God
despite the terrible things that happen
to us
I couldn't deny the existence of it
never
I remember after the war and when I was
liberated in tourism stud there was a
big pile
of religious articles
feeling
prayer-books
and they just thought were the people
who honed them and I picked a pair never
use them ever since and I don't know who
the person is who owned them and the
prayer-book is an old prayer book
printed in
Prague Czechoslovakia
who knows who Adam
the book was is falling apart must have
been used many time
but I'm glad I'm using them
it's a big pile Mount
thousands
I was a very very mature very sheltered
little girl and then the world war broke
out I grew up overnight I just really
did my parents were not even 40 years
old my mother my father there were young
people and my father went out one day to
the dog store to get some medicine and
never came back never came back you know
the Germans went out there all these
trucks around and they picked up people
and there was a blockade he called it
like a blockade so he went out to the
dog store he never came back he went out
in the ghetto in the ghetto was quiet
you know then there was a baby knew that
the Germans are coming we didn't go out
understates but nothing was happening
and the doctor was like from here to the
end of the building did anybody see no
he never came back so we assumed that
you know there was a lot of people they
were catching people like a dog catcher
you know when a dog catcher goes out and
catches dogs anybody day so understood
they picked up so my father was picked
up you don't know oh we know we know he
was so yeah the people told us that do
you wait he went out and he never came
back and then my mother and my younger
brother was left with myself and um my
mother was very dependent on my father
she really was and she she went to
pieces when they took him away she
really she didn't care she really didn't
care if she living to know so he had to
watch over her because she kind of like
designed you know there was a care of
you and you couldn't go out and she she
didn't care she just she really wanted
to die but somehow I say I was able to
you know to watch over her and then we
needed papers working papers it I
remember I went over to a gentleman I
said to him I give you a diamond link
give me papers for my class for my
mother and get all the 15 who would dare
do that I did he did give me the paper
and he did buy a little time for for
them you know without papers you just
didn't have a chance
wherever I went I saw people laying
under still it's dying like you see the
kids in Cambodia now you see that's when
I look at those pictures we get such a
pain wherever you saw you so just agony
in pain some of the Polish day was the
aka the Polish resistance to to the
Germans they were trying to bring in
some ammunition
you had to pay it in gold so people got
to get on and we got gold P but I over
got and we paid but was nothing very
little very little came in some of them
were honest some of them were not honest
you had to pay in advance and they said
to him look we're gonna deliver you too
many rifles but when he loved all of us
and you gave him the gold and some of
them came in and some of them didn't it
was just ugly worth they're messy and
with the food the same thing he said
they smuggled it in through the sewers
yeah were these sewers large enough for
people well it wasn't that large enough
but you know you managed you were able
to bring some stuff in some people were
hiding themselves in the sewers too
because later on when the Germans really
set up there this is 1943 I was taking
out I was living in the ghetto to 1943
May night main May 10th you know but the
jewish Warsaw Uprising was I was taking
out almost one of the last people from
the warsaw ghetto were you fighting with
armed
we will fight you know what we did in
the warsaw ghetto which is you know a
lot of people don't know and they feel
that we weren't really very passive but
if you want to look at history and I'm
sure you know enough that countries like
France or Belgium or Holland they went
in a few days the Germans came and took
over the Warsaw Ghetto was holding up
for four weeks even Poland didn't hold
out for four weeks you said you were
married I got married together why my
father before he was taken away
it felt like I was very young he wanted
to protect me you know a lot of people
got married together amazingly everybody
got married because he felt well you're
gonna die anyway might as well you
wanted to attach yourself to someone you
wanted to be have some connections with
somebody else my father was afraid if
something is going to happen to him I
should have someone to help me to take
care of him so I met I was 16 years old
when I was mad did your father pick out
the young man you know he was interested
he came into my heart father the girl
also stole my husband at a bakery so he
came in and he knew me I would have
never married under ordinary
circumstances I don't think it would
ever happen but my father felt look he
was 10 years older than I am and he will
take care of me and and we had it better
because he wasn't here he his father
wasn't the bacon of business so you know
people used to bring down I mean Colt
diamond for a loaf of bread so he had
food my father felt that I'm gonna be
well taken care if I marry him so I was
married and to get Oh sounds strange but
a lot of people learned to get oh you'd
be surprised really
oh so I was but his family my mother we
were together my mother was taken a few
days before and then they took us all to
my donek your husband - my husband to
myself so but when we went to my donek
this was just the most terrible as much
as I experienced bad things after but
this was they put us in cattle cars and
they pushed in I don't know how many
people but they really wanted us to die
and we wind as those wagons um I don't
know how many people were do you but my
god or died in my arms my younger
brother was
and my husband's two sisters what's not
enough oxygen followed us people and
they kept doesn't as walkins for days
they wanted us to tie in the organs
you know the cattle cars but very little
windows how old was your brother maybe
13
he wasn't even spelled so you know when
my mother died my nerves said to myself
I ain't gonna bid I must be the only one
survivor for my family I'm gonna live I
made up my mind I'm gonna defy you I'm
not gonna give it because he wants me to
die I'm gonna live I'm gonna just be
very very strong
and I went to my Dominic this is the
interesting story but because when I
came to my donek and I went to they put
me in a block with 500 other women
somebody told me my mother's do you my
mother was taken a few days before I
they told you so I went to see her and
you know my mother was there so it's
like I lost her twice where we but she
was very lost she was lost
she was very passive she was very lost
and you know they gave you one portion
of white and one portion of food soup
for the day and I my mother became very
skinny and she was very thin and she was
they you know lost tail so I used to
bring her my soup to her in my and I
just cut off a little piece of bread and
I said to her you know somebody gave it
to me eat it and I used to give it to
her corn out because if she would say to
me eat a little bit I would eat I was
very hungry but I felt that she needs it
more than you know I was younger she
needs it more than myself so I used to
give it a soup and run out because I
didn't want to be tempted that I should
eat with her and she wasn't to get her
for she wasn't there camp at me for
about maybe six weeks two months
Ethel a few weeks they used to select
you know I have selections and one day
just before they took me to Auschwitz
I walked down with her and she went one
way and I went the other way and III had
a friend which we were hiding out in the
ghetto together we will just childhood
friends for many many years
she didn't left me she pulled me back I
said how can I let her go and she said
Helen you're not gonna help her you know
where she's going and I
I stayed then we I went to Auschwitz
they send us to oceans and I wasn't I
was the only one left from the whole
family my husband was separated from the
beginning two men went different and my
donek one of my husband sister was with
me and she was such a strong girl a
beautiful young woman maybe 25 26 and we
slept on the same bunk and she developed
diarrhea and she was very very cold and
she only wanted me to lay next to her to
warm her body but she she just didn't
feel anything she was she had very like
I don't know what you called it
dysentery or something it was just awful
I had to lay next to her because she was
dying and she said Helen please stay
next to me and a warm me and she was the
last one she went to she died in the bed
she lied and by an arms just like my
brother did it wasn't a bed it was a
bomb for five people you didn't have a
mattress store and she was laying there
and she was the smell was so awful I was
dying but she was so scared she was old
that's all she was crying I should stay
with him so I did I stayed till till she
became cold and stiff in my arms you
know sometimes at night I lay and I
can't believe what my eyes have seen I
really cannot believe it you know I
wasn't an outfit but whenever I got up
in the morning the lines were
unbelievable the kids used to come in
standing waiting to be count whenever I
used to get up in the morning I said my
god how can God allow this the kids were
standing in line they didn't know he see
they what they did they showed when you
went into the crematorium he saw our
camp
so they
so that people are working and they were
you know and like a Kemp going on so
when the people got off the boat the
Train what they saw they saw our cam
become a toy em so a little bit you know
like around the corner there were lines
every day there were lines of people and
of kids they bought a console from
Hungary once such little kids they were
waiting there
I just wanted God should strike me dead
I couldn't bear you I have nightmares
about those lines what did you say when
you first saw your husband again
what did you say oh I don't know we you
know
the man I married and the man he was
after the war wasn't the same person and
I'm sure I was not the same person
neither when I was at 16 and later on
but somehow we had a knee to each other
because he knew who I was he was the
only person who knew you know you feel
like you come from nothing well nothing
nobody knows you it's it's a very
strange feeling you need some contact
some connection
he was my connection and he was he knew
who I was and I knew who he was and we
stuck it out we met I don't know how
many years I don't know we're gonna be
maybe 25 or whatever we yeah two
children and he's very different he
copes differently than I do and we he
here to tell you the story [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know if it was worth
it I don't know if it was worth it
because - you know when I was in
concentration camp and even after I said
to myself you know after the war people
who learn they will know they will able
see you know the lamp but did we really
learn anything I don't know